I hope there is thereit's oh wait no I
can totally see him better oh this is
cheating that I'm cheating real bad oh
no oh don't do this the games crash the
games is like please stop hey everybody
welcome to the potato mode the show
retake your favorite games and turn them
into mush although we're playing a brand
new game that just came out predator
hunting grounds isn't that right Ben
that's true John Luke we're here
yeah it's predator editor and we're
gonna ruin it that's we're here for we
don't run it all into the grid on the
ground let's start this game up we're
gonna hit quit play here's hoping they
go pretty quick cuz I got time to bleed
are you familiar with a predator the
musical no not oh my god is it just for
us to kill time yeah that was really
good I'm really I'm really digging it
I'm glad that you sure yeah I'm really I
was surprised you never heard of it
we're still waiting oh my god what I
watched a whole musical song it bleeds
we can kill it if it bleeds we can kill
it
if it's a server we can cue it oh oh my
god happens I have aged many years
classic I love it all right I'm excited
to see what the potato fire does to some
of these effects like the cloaking
effect right this predators out here do
be looking kind of thick though they do
Oh God what is that sound that's some
footsteps wait wait what what is going
on what is happening I don't know if it
got really really wild there what hello
video games hit the game broke
yeah the cages broke like the games on
your cool touch the profile inspector
yet okay alright video game is that weed
oh yeah it is look at that oh did you
just jump right in there oh oh hey guys
you go on ahead I'm just gonna hang out
over here you know what I'm sayin I
definitely want these settings oh it
looks like like far cry
Wow where I try to run out my old
computer like the original one yikes
oh that actually removed a lot that
let's just get real load there well not
even work no signal come back there it
is yeah keep that keep all the buttons
oh man it is far cry 1 this is so much
to take in don't hello I don't know I
don't begin the game likes it who is
that messy person oh that's me that's
you covered of what well you did get
beat up on a hole punched Oh took all
the damage Wow
yikes oh that already looks pretty darn
bad let's make it worse
let's do it oh he's so smooth oh boy you
know the
nice the potato fire making things
smooth is is I'll never get tired to see
you know it's pretty good you have a
haircut you're gonna know my hair's gone
I think I had um I'm not sure which hair
I had hair one or two oh yeah here one
two hair options and they're both
they're both nothing
yeah let's good thank you going oh wait
nope you can't even see them okay hold
on there we go
quick play fireteam I'm I'm really
scared for when you play as the predator
because they have all those different
vision modes I'm most curious about well
let's see how the the human looks for a
hot second okay okay alright this is
just the inside of an oven whoa ah so
that that looks like it's it's come to
be true that some of the ground is gone
oh look at these these poor poor souls
whoa the grounds go terrifying I think
your visibilities gotten much better
this might be cheating cuz I don't think
the predator has as much covered as they
could even though this is for science
you would never use this for illegal
means oh I keep thinking I'm gonna fall
into the ground
yeah doesn't say that looked like it
could have been a big drop and I got
scared
I'm just waiting to fall through it
doesn't might work out better for them
okay I bet there's some geometry I can't
see these where'd he go where'd he go I
hope there is there is oh wait no I can
totally see him better oh this is
cheating that I'm cheating real bad oh
no oh don't do this the games crash the
games is like please stop whoa
oh look at that like the stairs going
down underneath the that's weird
stairs go down I'm just gonna follow
these guys I think I'm in a field whoa
dude look underneath us found the escape
helicopters I'm hiding out on that
copter do you think its wings there
until you show up I think that's what
that is create a pop I don't know I oh
the blood splatters on your screen or Oh
predator predator predator predator okay
there he was invisible okay like
sometimes it seems like I can see it
better and other times I can I'm
surprised at how well you're navigating
all of this to be honest
it's too bad occasionally I run up
against like some invisible geometry
oh wait what I must have been shooting
something because he wasn't docking okay
look there's like a building underneath
us is the the copter mad it's a helmet
right here oh he can't pick up oh yeah
get to the chopper yeah I made it
man we escaped you escaped to the potato
mode oh he's so angry
alright I mean you would be too if you
had to deal with you should show us what
the predator looks like with the mask
off Oh No
[ __ ] yeah likes like someone chopped up
like a headcrab oh boy
you seem to be missing literally
everything on the screen I'm ready I'm
ready to go on a journey
oh that smoke is coming alive
okay all right uh you can see your bars
at least so that's good that is true
that is good uh heat vision me oh boy
that's that's not how that works mostly
I think but that I thought it was gonna
be worse I feel like I'm at a little bit
of a disadvantage that one map here for
a sec oh cool haha I know where they
perfect here hit me a me with that
invisibility let me see what that's like
that stays intact yeah that's that's
pretty good look it's just taking in
like a like a mirror so it's just
mirroring the bad textures perfect more
of them just what we needed
there they are found him oh yeah wow
that was quick here we go
I'll look at the hitmarkers just a giant
block I just start punching him those
punches you down people in like three
hits no no the doorway there's yes get
out of there
what there's so much green oh no are you
gonna self destruct
okay I'm gonna self destruct yeah I'll
take it well
why is he oh he killed you anyway but
it's still gonna blow up yeah right
running away
oh my god yeah I got them on yeah I'll
take it
yeah that's fantastic
yeah you can't have gotten the ball if
someone had to have ran away
no they're all dead I got them all you
got them all oh my goodness fantastic so
a good way to send that off with a bang
haha alright everybody this has been
predator hunting grounds honestly that
went pretty well
I'm pretty happy with that yeah I didn't
know what I kind of expected going in
but like that was a wild ride from the
moment we decided to lower the graphics
like in the game all the way through see
playing with the potato mode stuff on
all right guys have you enjoyed this
episode of potato mode make sure to
subscribe so you can see more and why
don't you go give us a recommendation
for what you'd like to see potato fide
mix in the comments see you next time
mmm
if it bleeds we can kill it
you